bonjour m aussi ça avant tout des
supporters déchaînés moi ce que j'adore
c'est les supporters marseillais qui
débrief les matchs en vidéo et qui ont
la défaite un peu amer c'est très très
drôle on regarde et on commence avec ben
vous un culte moi je la croise
d'ailleurs fort bangguo qui écoutent
avec son son où est ce qu'on va qu'est
ce qu'on fait regardez je suis énervé
rond je suis énervé ce soir parce
qu'elle n'a pas fait un pli
c'est malheureux c'est que je repars
chez man les commères j'ai passé une
semaine de mer et bon jeu mais c'est
quoi une guilde mais bon je le passais
agacé c'est à dire que comme en quelques
jours un café gros ne portent pas de
casque
[Musique]
j'embrasse mon goût c'est ma famille que
la famille j'adore ceux ci copie
de plus
alors et un support fait aussi de longue
date marseillais au caractère bien
trempé
est-ce que tu connais rené malleville
bien sûr un peu oui elle lui livre d'or
à hiva ouais c'est vrai bonbon il me
fait rire il nous fait marrer j'adore
alors elle adore regarder la 6e ces
conneries là c'est un petit peu son
repas se fait via le web qui éparpillés
aux quatre coins du monde qui ce matin
c'est l'aveu grauby et qui se dit mais
nous un peu plus pour des cons carrément
s'est fait défaut limité fort ici même
pamela fazli news ont mis le sable de
rivière
[Applaudissements]